- I'm making thousands nearly every day
from my phone and my laptop.
- [Narrator] Millionaire
coaches always intrigue us.
But like many, we're skeptical of them too.
Especially the ones who guarantee
that they can help us turn
a few hundred dollars into millions.
So when Steven Dux, an online millionaire coach
inquired if he could be a sponsor, in order to
share his story and his method
we had our reservations.
But then we realized, it would be a great
opportunity to explore this phenomenon
of millionaire coaches, and agree to have Steven
on the show
only under the conditions that he would be
honest about his life,
his work, and of course, allow our audience
to ask him anything.
(electronic music)
- Hi, my name is Steven Dux, and I'm a millionaire.
I've turned 27,000 into $5 million within
four years by trading stocks.
I've come here to answer any questions.
(chill electronic music)
- Maybe you're the first millionaire
I've ever had a chance to
have an actual conversation with.
- I guess this wasn't gonna be my first question,
but how old are you?
- I'm 25-years-old, so I'm not that far from you.
- Oh, I have grandchildren probably
as old as you are.
- Has anybody ever thought you were lying,
like when you mentioned it to them?
- Well, my neighbor think I'm a drug dealer.
- Do you think it's ethical to accumulate
so much wealth and not give back to society?
- Well it depends on how they accumulate
their wealth,
and if they're helping people while accumulating wealth,
I think it's ethical.
- This is an oversimplification, but
if you made $2 million,
it might be fair to say that 20 people
lost $100,000. Are you okay with that?
- Oh, very interesting question. It's a
very competitive society, so you have to be
responsible for your own mistakes, not blame it on others.
- Are you a math whiz?
- Sort of.
- What's 88 times 75?
- That, I don't know.
- What does a day look like in your life?
- I wake up at 9:00 a.m., around 8:00 or 9:00
and I look at the general market and make a decision,
should I trade today or not. If I trade I will stay about extra two hours.
- That's like your first thing you do?
- Yes, the first thing I do.
- Whoa, okay, nice.
- After that, I'll just go to lunch.
- Could I ask what you eat for your lunch?
- What I eat for lunch?
- Usually?
- Chipotle.
(both laughing)
- Nice. Good choice, good choice.
- What's the craziest thing you've spent
a large amount of money on?
- Okay, so I'm a huge car fan. I had a
Ferrari 488 Spider, that cost about around 500k.
- Did you like grow up like
being financially stable or...
- So, I was an exchange
student from from China.
I came here when I was 16.
Back in, I would say the '70s,
my mom was already a millionaire
and my dad was a soldier, which is considered to
be poor in that state.
So, my mom had my brother,
and we had to move to a different city.
My mom sold all their business to my dad,
and my dad become a multimillionaire,
a lot of millions.
He basically change into
an entire different person.
There is more family violence, there's more,
you know, cursing and in the families
and my mom was basically in suffering, and he
wasn't appreciative at all from my mom
basically give all her money to him, to start
as an investment at the beginning.
I'm not comfortable seeing
that type of people.
And even though my dad has millions,
I'm not looking up to him.
So my mom always taught me that it doesn't
really matter you have money or not.
We have to respect people,
we have to respect people who help you at the beginning.
I want to, you know, become
the opposite of my dad.
Even though I went from the bottom to the top,
I still won't become the person that he did.
- Do you ever think of the fact that people
like Warren Buffett, or Ray Dalio
come out really strongly
against day trading?
How so many financial experts would say
that day trading is akin to gambling?
- How many professional football players
can make over $2 million a year?
Not that many.
And how many people try to
play professional football? A lot.
And the only successful people can be
about within 10%.
Same thing with day tradings.
And if you're going into this industry,
if you're not prepared to be the top percent,
and you just want to get in there and
make quick money, then you're going to be
the 90% people going to lose money.
- Do you believe that anyone
can become a millionaire?
- I don't believe anyone
can become a millionaire.
Because a lot of people don't really have
the motivations to do it.
Second, they don't really want
to step out their comfort zones.
- Do you ever feel anxious in how
you might calm your own anxiety?
- I do get a lot of, you know,
anxious at the beginning as well.
The first major mistakes you make, the second thought
is: I want to make that money back.
Now as soon as you have a second thought, you make
the second mistake, then it's gonna chain reaction.
You keep making mistakes until
you blow up your account.
The way to deal with that, just shut down your
computer and come back fresh the next day.
And not all people can do that. It's very difficult
to control your emotions,
especially, you know, playing with real money,
but it just takes practices.
- It seems as though, when you describe your methods,
you can make money at will.
If that's the case, then why sell classes?
If you searched about day trading,
there's a lot of schemes.
I'm the victim of that type of courses. So I
generated one course, it's full with content.
No bullshit. Goes straight to the point. I want to
become the opposite of how they're selling courses.
- But if it was really about helping people, and
you're financially set, you've got millions of dollars,
- Yeah.
- Then wouldn't you just wanna give away this information, or...
Or, charge considerably less?
- When I studied, I spent 10 hours a day,
365 days with no break, that's for the first year.
I can't just give stuff out there for free.
- Has your millions brought
you a lot of happiness?
- The more money you gain in your young age,
the less friends you have.
It's because you don't
really have a similar topic.
And once you spend majority
of your time, you know, diving into the market -
and a lot of people in college,
they're spending their time partying,
and building their relationships -
you guys don't really have a similar topic.
- Has being a millionaire
impacted your relationships?
- Well, you can kind of tell people are
kind of come for you as a person or for your money.
Being a millionaire, you get a lot of,
straightforward, gold-diggers, yeah.
- Where do you usually meet people?
- Probably workspace, I work a lot.
I don't really go out that much.
- Do you have a girlfriend?
- Nope.
- No?
- Yeah, for now, no.
- Do you think you need to, when you date somebody,
you need to find somebody else who
shares that interest with you?
- Yes, and that's the reason why it's
so hard to find a girlfriend.
When I meet people I will seem a little bit shy,
and don't really know how to talk to people.
And when I talk to girls, you know, pretty much
50% of the info in my head are about
you know, generating datas
and engineerings and numbers.
Don't really sharing the same interest,
it's hard to get along.
- Have you had like a successful long-term
relationship where you felt like someone
was interested in who you are
as a person and not your money?
- Yes, I had one but it was a heartbreaking one. That's
where I started trading and trying to be better of myself.
- So that heartbreak inspired you to start trading?
- Yes.
- Wow. So you were not a millionaire during this relationship?
- No, I was not, yeah, nope.
- Have you had contact with this person?
Does she now see like, man, I missed out?
- I don't think she cares.
Yeah, that's the problem.
So I started dating this girl when I was 19
and at that time I wasn't trading,
I wasn't have any type of money at all.
I was an engineering student,
I was so dedicated to this relationship.
And I spent pretty much all my money
to bought a ring.
And once I bought a ring, about to propose,
and she turned around and said she was with another man.
And that's, yeah, that's where it it just,
I turned into a completely different person.
Once you go through a breakup, and first thing
you want to do is you want to,
you know, you think yourself are not good
and you want to get better.
And I started to, you know, start investing and
save my money and go to the gym, become better myself,
and been going good since there.
- Wow, I feel like that emotional driving force was
something that kind of led you to kind of take away
the negativity and--
- And it's really tough to go through as a,
you know, 20-year-old kid at the same--
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's so true. Well, thank you so much
for sharing. That was really cool,
being able to hear your story.
- No problem.
- I appreciate that.
- Thank you for watching the video. Steven,
would you like to mention where
they can find information on your products?
- So you can find my courses at stevenduxi.com,
and currently we're building this AI system and coding
my strategies of the scanners, currently
is still in beta test versions.
So we're likely to release during the spring
and we're also accepting a limited amount of spots
so if you wanna get your emails, down,
the link in descriptions, I will be happy to accept that.
- Please like and subscribe if
you enjoyed the video. Bye.
- Bye.